حكم قاضٍ
فيدرالي بضرورة مثول سناتور كارولينا الجنوبية ليندسي جراهام
أمام هيئة محلفين كبرى في جورجيا
تحقق في جهود دونالد ترامب
لإلغاء انتخابات عام 2020 في تلك
الولاية كمحامي دفاع جنائي
ومحامي القانون الدستوري ،
هل يمكنك أن تعطينا فكرة عن كيفية
من الأهمية بمكان أن جراهام قد تم
استدعاؤه للإدلاء بشهادته
جيدًا سارة ، فمن المحتمل أن يكون هذا أمرًا
مهمًا للغاية ولهذا السبب كانت
المكالمة الهاتفية التي أجراها السناتور جراهام مع
وزير الخارجية هنا في
جورجيا في نفس الوقت الذي
كان يحاول فيه الأشخاص العاملون مع حملة ترامب.
لنشر
معلومات خاطئة حول الانتخابات المزعومة
وتزوير التصويت في هذه الولاية
وما أعتقد أن المدعي العام
يريد أن يعرفه هو ما إذا كان السناتور جراهام
ينسق مكالماته مع ترامب أو
مع سيناتور الحملة الانتخابية غراهام
على عكس رودي جولياني أو بعض هؤلاء
الشهود الآخرين لا يفعل ذلك.  لديه أي
امتياز بين المحامي والموكل يدعي أنه
ليس لديه أي امتياز تنفيذي
cl  يهدف إلى أن الشيء الوحيد الذي
يحاول ادعاءه والذي يجب أن يمنعه
من الإدلاء بشهادته هو
حقه الدستوري كعضو في مجلس الشيوخ في
القيام بأنشطة تشريعية بشكل جيد ،
وقد نفى القاضي أنه على الأقل بقدر
ظهوره الآن لا يزال بإمكانه الاعتراض
على أسئلة معينة  ولكن في النهاية
سيتعين عليه الرد
إذا تحدث هو وترامب عن هذه
المكالمات وإذا كانت تلك المكالمات محاولة
للتدخل في الانتخابات ، لذلك قد
يكون الأمر بالغ الأهمية ،
هل يمكنني أن أسألك لأنني أفهم
أن نطاق الشهادة محدود للغاية
هل هناك سؤال
تعتقد أنه الأهم الذي
سيُطرح على غراهام ،
نعم ، ما الذي قاله
لك ترامب ، هل سألت ترامب نوع الأسئلة التي
يجب
أن تطرحها في تلك المكالمة الهاتفية
لوزير الخارجية ، ماذا كان لديك
سبب القيام بذلك هو أنك كنت جزءًا من أي
مناقشات أخرى حول
التدخل في الانتخابات في جورجيا حول
هذه القائمة البديلة للناخبين ، لذا
فهي جوهر شهادته.
على الأقل ما يريد d.a معرفته هو
هل عملت مع ترامب ، هل كنت تحاول
أن تكون جزءًا من جهودهم
لإلغاء الانتخابات وهذا أمر
محوري للغاية في هذا التحقيق
وغيره